hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot here in the e a booth at e3
2014 standing here with Brian who is the
presentation director for madden 15 what
does a presentation director do kind of
everything he works on timing pacing
making sure we're paying off great
moments in the game telling stories it's
kind of all-encompassing yeah is that
why you would say you love games is
telling the story telling the story I
left on the story of the game I think in
a normal football play there's so much
stuff that's happening and we're just
trying to pay things off like that we're
trying to say that you know big play
happens how do you see the celebrations
how do you see the you know or how do
you see the person just it was just
really upset with the play that he just
had things like that so absolutely well
I was telling you I'm a big Seahawks fan
and so I've been really excited to see
my boy Richard Sherman up here and all
of my my favorite Seahawks players and
trailers for Madden and you know I love
the story of football too I think that's
why I got so into football was the story
of those players and why I've become
more interested in sports game so how is
that story going to be shown in Madden
what are the in this version of madden
how are we going to get in verse this
time well the biggest thing is probably
our post play that's how you tell
stories right like we just sent for us
it used to be where we would cut away
immediately after the play and kind of
just it's more like hiding what's going
on right this year everyone's alive our
worlds alive so you know after a big
plays after touchdowns everyone's
celebrating if someone falls down a guy
comes over and picks them up that's how
we're really going to show off the
stories this year for us it's a really
big deal that we're not hiding anything
we're staying on the field and that's we
wanted to do very cool and so as those
stories develop we're going to be able
to see them more vividly oh yeah
absolutely and the graphic fidelity this
year is incredible we finally have a gin
for game here I mean this I'll tell you
what for me it's the helmets like your
Seattle fan so we have the shiny in the
mat on the helmet right and we see that
and it is you can look at it so close we
have shots to pay that off it just looks
brilliant oh so you really get the sense
that you're seeing those actual players
as opposed to more like
if I'd representations of them yeah it's
um super 8 years I was an Emmy
award-winning director of photography
with NFL films and so for me I've been
on hundreds of football fields and when
I play this game I have some you nose
like a stage abou moments right where
it's like I feel like I've been there
before like if you like is that kind of
reality it's pretty cool very cool so
yeah sorry it fools us oh yeah so having
been someone that's been that close to
these real games how does it feel to
kind of be able to create them yourself
the way that you would like to see them
I mean it's so much easier and so much
more difficult I mean it's um for us
it's like you know your imagination is
endless right and so you just keeps
turning and turning and turning and you
want to do so much that you can't do
everything it and then also staying true
to the fans and what the fans want for
us so it's we kind of look at it as a
hyper broadcast so we can break the
rules but we were very cognizant of
which rules were breaking okay so we
know that the the emotional aspect the
visual aspect is really evolving here
what about the gameplay itself are there
going to be any big changes to that huge
changes I mean first of all quarterback
accuracy is really really important this
year right so quarterback accuracy
that's all offense but for defense we
actually have we're saying defense is
fun this year like usually I'm like a
detriment to my own gameplay when I play
defense so I wanted to really have a
game where gameplay where I can actually
play defense and actually impact the
game and so what we have going on this
year is we have offensive line jump the
snap plays we have great zone coverage
we went out actual defensive backfield
players from the NFL and they kind of
said well this is actually how I would
react to that play and we listen to them
right we listen to the pros in the
industry so for that we also have effort
caches which is really neat you know
incomplete passes things like that where
you actually see a receiver commit dive
you know reach for it and everything
like that so it's pretty cool so working
with those actual players to create
their likenesses and again
what has that been like and how much of
the real players are we seeing reflected
in this game we're seeing a lot of it
we're seeing a lot of it first of all in
image right and player like this you
look at we have great payoff shots to
where we're showing our coaches our
players you know Kaepernick I don't know
just saw our image that we released but
I mean we have care for next tattoos and
and in that that's that personality that
shows through you know and that helps us
tell stories too great well I'm very
excited to hear this story thank you so
much for all of your time thank you
check out Mountain 15 and let me know
what you think tweet at an oppressor
with a hashtag gamespot III